stop worrying and and don't learn to
live and love the bomb but stop worrying
first of all Iran is so far away from
having a nuclear weapon I know there's
all this reports he's alarmist reports
Iran has enough you rich uranium to
build a bomb tomorrow well building a
bomb is not as simple as it sounds yes
the designs are on the internet and you
can but to actually create a nuclear
weapon is going to be so difficult for
Iran to do quietly secretly yes they
have in they've enriched uranium to 3%
or 4% whatever the number is that is
useful for as fuel to then enrich it to
90 whatever percent they would have to I
mean it would have to be done under the
watchful eyes of the IAEA so we would
know about it the minute they do it it's
not like they have this other secret
facility or at least even the IAEA
doesn't think they have the secret
facility where they're doing exactly
what they're doing in front of the IAEA
and they can then secretly go out and
and enrich to a higher level some even
once you've enriched it to a higher
level surely you'd want to test a
nuclear weapon before you just fired it
off I mean it Ron is so far away from
testing a nuclear weapon so we would
even know in the North Koreans tested
weapons we don't we're not even sure
that they worked we do know that Israel
has nuclear weapons we do know they have
a delivery system for those nuclear
weapons they have them kinds of missiles
that could deliver accurate missiles
that could deliver a nuclear weapon to
Iran Iran is so far away from having
that ability I mean some would say oh
you're being you know naive they could
do it in a year they could do it in two
years but to be so many signals before
that happened that we could get we could
become really alarmed if Iran suddenly
shuts down the IAEA cameras 24 hours a
day on their facility where it's using
nutrition you're right they shut down
those cameras you can say okay that's
the beginning of a cause of alarm what
are they doing that they want to get rid
of the IAEA inspectors so I mean we're
so far away from that I think that we
should let the IAEA do their job we
should at least talk to the Iranians I
mean the thing is that when they have
the technology to enrich uranium
you're not going to bomb that technology
out of them there's plenty of people in
Iran who can start up a centrifuge
program even if this program was
completely eliminated so the question
now becomes how do we incentivize the
Iranians to never take that step we know
that they have the knowledge to build
centrifuges to enrich uranium and a lot
of people analysts will tell you nuclear
sciences will say it's not a big step to
then go to a bomb it is actually a
bigger step than we think because you
have to test it you have to create that
perfect sphere you have to have the
mechanism after the delivery system to
deliver it presumably you want a second
strike capability not just a first
strike capability because the first
strike capability and somebody has a
second strike on you you're done so you
want to have this that to be unequal in
terms of nuclear power with Israel for
example so how do we incentivize them to
not take that step and that's where
negotiations come in because there are
plenty of countries that do have that
ability Japan is one there never
incentivized to go and build a bomb
Brazil South Africa these are countries
that have the ability to enrich uranium
have the ability to even probably build
a bomb if they wanted to but what stops
them from doing it well there's they'd
have no they have no incentive
none whatsoever they have all the
disincentives to build a bomb so what we
have to do is figure out what how to
disincentivize Iran from ever taking
that step